This is a story that the ancient
Egyptians predicated their society on,
and to understand this story,
the first thing you have to know is what
the characters were in these characters
were gods.
There's four of them.
Although the Egyptians had far more than
four gods.
You might think of these as the central
Gods and you might think what is the
central God and then you might think,
well,
imagine that the gods compete for
dominance across time in people's
imaginations and some gods when they
occupied the primary position of
dominance in the hierarchy,
in the dominance hierarchy of gods,
and those are ideals and ideals compete
across time for dominance and their
embodied,
and so when diverse tribal people come
together,
they throw all their gods into the ring
and they fight across time and something
emerges as a victor,
and that's the emergence of monotheism
out of polytheism and it.
It parallels the development of a
unified morality in within each of us as
we develop across time and the the god
that emerges as dominant across time
bears a substantial,
represent a substantial
resemblance.
Imagine you have a set of gods in this
locale that are competing across time
and something emerges as dominant,
and then over here you have another set
of gods that compete across time for
dominance and something emerges.
You'll see major commonalities across
the two things that emerge and the
reason for that is because the emergent,
the process of emergence that gives rise
to both of them is similar in both
situations and that's part of what
accounts for the cross cultural
similarity of high order religious
ideas.
All right.
Anyways,
you need to know the characters.
Oh,
Cyrus Cyrus is the old king.
He's Dumbledore.
For all intents and purposes,
he's the king.
He's the.
He's the spirit that established the
Egyptian state.
When he was young,
he was a great hero,
but now he's old and he's willing.
He's our cat and he's willfully blind.
That's Cyrus.
He has a brother Seth.
Seth is set and set is Satan because the
word Satan comes from the word Seth and
set via the Coptic Christians.
So,
so.
So he's a precursor to the western idea
of Satan.
You have isis.
Isis is queen of the underworld,
and Isis was the goddess of a religious
structure that prevailed across
thousands and thousands of years.
Isis and you have horace.
Horace is a Falcon,
and the Egyptian,
I.
everyone's knows that.
I write the eye with the open pupil.
That's horace.
And Horace is a fall can because falcons
can see way better.
They can see better than us.
They can see better than anything else
except for eagles,
and they fly above everything.
Zazu in lion king is horace,
and move Fossa is Cyrus and scar is seth
and there no specific representation of
Isis,
but the closest there is in that story
is probably the queen of the hyenas.
That's played by.
Who's the actress?
Um
Hm.
Yes.
Whoopi Goldberg.
That's right.
Because they inhabit.
She's like the queen of the underworld,
right?
She's the queen of the hygienists that
live out among the death,
but.
Okay.
Anyways,
Seth Osiris,
seth,
Isis,
and horace.
Here's how the story goes on.
Cirrus is a great king.
He established the Egyptian state.
You could think about him as the
embodiment of the,
of Egyptian customs and tradition.
You can think about him as the thing
that the pyramid represents.
All right,
but he was great when he was young,
but he's not young anymore.
He's old and he's willfully blind,
and what that means is that he doesn't
see what he could see.
He refuses to see what he could see.
Why is,
oh,
cirrus old and willfully blind because
that's what culture is.
It's a paternal spirit that's old and
willfully blind and it's always that
way,
always that way,
and the reason for that is because it's
a construction of the dad.
The Dad aren't alive,
they can't,
so they're out of date and they can
update themselves anymore and you
inhabit their corpse.
And that's actually what happens in an
earlier story that I'll tell you next
week.
The early Mesopotamian gods inhabited
the corpse of their father,
roughly speaking anyway.
So,
oh,
Cyrus was great and when he was young,
but he hasn't young anymore.
He's old and he's willfully blind.
He won't look where he knows he should
look.
He doesn't have the energy or maybe he
doesn't have the spirit.
His brother Seth is not a good guy and
Cyrus knows it,
but he underestimates his malevolence
and power,
and so seth wants to rule the kingdom.
So what does that mean?
It's easy.
Every stable society is,
is threatened by willful blindness and
malevolence always.
Every bureaucracy has that proclivity to
stagnate and to become blind.
That's why corporations die all the
time.
That's why a fortune 500 company only
last 30 years.
It's why we have to have elections.
It's to stop the Dad from staying in
control for too long.
Seth,
oh,
Cyrus turns a blind eye to seth.
Seth is happy about that.
Same thing happens in the lion king,
roughly speaking.
Seth one day waits for Cyrus to make a
mistake and to be weak,
and he attacks him and he chops it up
into pieces and he distributes the
pieces across the entire Egyptian state.
In fact,
the Egyptians regarded their provinces
as pieces of,
oh,
Cyrus's body.
Okay,
so now you can kill.
Oh,
cyrus,
because he's a god.
And why is he god a God?
Because he represents the of structure.
There's always structure.
It can't be destroyed.
It always reconstitutes itself,
it can be hurt and broken into pieces,
which is exactly what happens to a
cyrus.
Things fall apart.
Why?
Because they get old and because
malevolence undermines them.
That's what the Egyptians were trying to
sort out.
Okay,
so seth distributed says,
oh,
cyrus all over Egypt.
So he can't get himself back together.
Right?
Things fall apart and they can't be
brought back together.
But the spirit of Vocera is still lives
in the pieces.
So what happens?
Orders demolished.
What would you expect?
Chaos emerges.
That's isis.
Isis is queen of the underworld.
She's Cyrus's wife,
order and chaos.
Just like the Yin and the Yang order
collapses upcoming the queen of the
underworld.
She's looking for order.
Chaos cries out for order.
She goes all around Egypt trying to put
our.
So Cyrus back together.
It's a state of chaos.
She finds this fellas.
She makes herself pregnant with it.
And what does that mean?
Well,
it means it's like it's like Japan in
the belly of the whale.
That thing has the potential to reemerge
this.
The thing that collapses into its
pieces.
It's still alive.
It can unite with the chaos and produce
something new.
That's the story of the disillusion of
structure into chaos and then it's
reverification.
Ice just makes herself pregnant.
She goes back down to the underworld.
She gives birth to horace.
Horace is the Egyptian Ayesha.
He's the son of the great father and the
great mother.
He's a.
he's a messianic figure and in fact,
much of the mythology that described
horace was extracted without much
modification and then attributed to
Christ.
Very much memory and you can read about
the parallels.
You can read about it online if you
want.
There's any number of parallels and of
course there is the mythology that the
Jews came out of Egypt and of course the
Christians,
he emerged from the Jews and so there
was a tremendous influence of Egyptian
thinking on the development of these
later ideas and you see pictures of Isis
with horace on her lap that are
virtually identical in content and form
to the later pictures of Mary with the
infant Christ.
But that's the holy mother of God and
the hero.
It's.
It's not a Christian motif.
It's far deeper than a Christian motif.
It's a human motif.
So Isis,
queen of the underworld gives birth to
horace.
Horace grows up outside the kingdom.
Why?
In underworld?
Because that's what human beings do.
You're alienated from your culture
always.
Why?
It's old and dead and corrupt.
And so that leaves you growing up in
chaos.
Uh,
what would you call alienated from your
fundamental culture?
That's the story of adolescence.
Horace grows up.
He can see that's what differentiates
them from,
oh,
Cyrus,
that's why he's a faulconer.
He goes and has a fight with seth.
And now the difference between those
Cyrusone and Horace is that horse does
not underestimate seth.
He knows exactly what he's up against.
He goes and has a terrible battle with
him trying to get his kingdom back.
Something else that's echoed in the lion
king story and well,
Horus and seth are fighting seth
terrorists out one of his eyes.
Now,
why?
Because Seth is the embodiment of
destruction and malevolence,
and no matter how conscious you are,
if you encounter that even voluntarily,
the probability that it's going to
damage your consciousness is
extraordinarily high.
That's white.
People don't do it,
so the eyes torn out,
but seth is defeated and Horace banishes
him to the nether regions of the
kingdom.
You can't kill them.
Why?
Because the malevolent destructive
force,
the threatened states never dies.
It's always there.
You can only remove it temporarily.
Now Horace is King Pharaoh,
King God.
He's got his eye and so you think,
well,
he's going to just pop that back in his
hand and then he's going to be able to
lead.
He's going to be able to take his place
at the upper most pantheon,
pantheon of gods properly,
but that isn't what he does.
He takes his eye and he goes back to the
underworld,
just like Pinocchio,
going into the depths to rescue Japan
and down there is the spirit of Cyrus
who's who's extent as a kind of half dad
ghost,
and it gives,
oh,
Cyrus's,
I now we'll cyrus can see.
So what does that mean?
You go down into the chaotic,
when threatened by malevolence,
even to the point of damage to your
consciousness.
You go down into the chaos and you find
the dead spirit of your tradition and
you give it vision and so provided with
vision or Cyrus regenerates and then no
Osiris and horus go back up to to to the
world linked together and rule jointly,
and the Egyptians believed that the
Pharaoh who had an immortal spirit was
the embodiment of the conjunction of
Horus and Osiris,
and that's what gave him sovereignty.
So when you think about how brilliant
that is,
the Egyptians are trying to puzzle out
who should lead,
who should be feral and what do you have
to be if you're going to be feral in
order for things to work,
you have to be awake to malevolence and
chaos and you have to embody your
tradition and that puts you at the
highest pinnacle of the dominant
structure.
It's and that's the same as.
It's the same thing.
It's the same thing as the battle
between the gods across centuries or
Ian's and the emergence of the highest
possible moral virtue as a consequence
of that competition.
It's the eye on the top of the pyramid,
right?
It's you know,
and the Washington monument,
there's a cap on the Washington
monument,
the protopic,
The Washington monument is a pyramid.
At the top of the pyramid is a cap.
It's made out of aluminum,
and the reason it's made out of aluminum
is because when they made the Washington
monument,
it was the most valuable metal known,
and so what does it mean?
It means there's a pyramid and there's
something at the top of it,
but the thing that's at the top of the
pyramid isn't the same as the rest of
the pyramid.
That's the thing.
The pyramid exists.
There's a dominance hierarchy.
Something climbs up to the top,
but it's not just at the top of one
pyramid.
It's at the top of all of them.
The thing that rises to the top of any
given pyramid is the same thing that can
dominate all pyramids.
It isn't good enough to be the best at a
dominance hierarchy.
What you want to be is the best at the
set of all possible dominance
hierarchies.
Right?
And that's the thing that's gold at the
top of the pyramid,
and that's the eye.
That's what the Egyptians figured out,
and what does that mean?
It means the thing that puts you at the
top is attention.
Pay Attention,
keep your eyes open.
It's not the same as thinking.
It's not the same thing.
It's like watching and the thing about
human beings is we can see,
we can see better than any other
creature except birds of prey and so our
capacity to see is in fact what we use
in the world.
Our brains are actually organized around
vision.
Unlike most animals,
their brains are organized around smell,
not us.
We can see we stand upright so we can
see a long distance and in our ability
to see is what saves us and what saves
our communities and that's what these
stories are trying to portray.
You might say,
well why didn't people just say so?
An answer to that is because they didn't
know.
It took a long time to figure it out
forever.
It's taken forever to figure it out.
It's.
It's part of what I hoped when I wrote
this book and part of the reason that
I'm teaching it is because it seems to
me that it would be useful for everyone
to actually understand this instead of
just having it told as a story.
It's like,
that's great,
man.
Yes,
you need the story,
but why not also just understand it
so
well,
so that's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to understand this,
so
that's good enough for today.